This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On any given day, there are a few different kinds of songs rattling around in my head. Some were just classics, like literal classics. Then there were songs that are just in there that are my own favorite. Songs that have carved out a space in my brain because I listened to them over and over and over. That's the song Solidarity by the band Scream. Oh, that song is so good. And then there's this other category of memorable songs, the ones that we all just kind of know. Songs that somehow, without anyone's permission, snuck their way into our collective unconscious
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在任何特定的一天里，我的脑海里总会盘旋着几种不同类型的歌。有些只是经典老歌，字面意思上的经典。还有一些则是纯粹我个人最喜欢的歌。那些在我的脑海中占据了一席之地的歌，因为我一遍又一遍、反反复复地听它们。那是乐队 Scream 的歌曲《Solidarity》。哦，那首歌太棒了。还有另一类令人难忘的歌，也就是我们大家似乎都略有耳闻的歌。有些歌不知怎么的，在未经任何人允许的情况下，悄悄溜进了我们的集体无意识中
and now are just lingering there for all eternity. These songs aren't necessarily good, but they usually have some undeniably catchy quality to them, a hook that worms its way into our brains and never leaves. Like this one. But I think there's one song in the last 25 years that exemplifies this phenomenon more than any other. It's a song that I think nearly every one of you will recognize. It is not my favorite. it. You did not ask for it, dear listener, but today's entire episode is devoted to who let the dogs out. Don't go. I swear, it'll be good because this is a story about how that song ended up stuck in all of our brains, and it's actually really complicated and it goes back decades and spans continents, and in the end, I think it tells us something
如今它们就永远地盘旋在那里。这些歌不一定很好听，但它们通常都有某种不可否认的抓耳特质，一种钻进我们脑海里就再也挥之不去的副歌。就像这首一样。但我认为，在过去 25 年里，有一首歌比任何其他歌曲都更能诠释这种现象。这是一首我认为你们几乎所有人都会听出来的歌。它并不是我最喜欢的。它。亲爱的听众，你并没有要求播放它，但今天的整期节目都在讨论《Who Let The Dogs Out》。别走。我发誓，这会很精彩，因为这是一个关于这首歌是如何最终卡在我们所有人脑海里的故事，而且它实际上非常复杂，历经数十年，跨越各大洲，最后，我认为它告诉了我们一些
important about inspiration and how creativity spreads, and about whether an idea can ever really belong to just one person. To tell the story, we have brought in the world's foremost expert on who let the dogs out. Yeah, it's an undisputed title. This is Ben Sisto. And about 10 years ago, Ben was reading the Wikipedia entry for the song Who Let The Dogs Out by the Bahamian. And I noticed this like missing citation.
关于灵感以及创造力如何传播的重要道理，也关于一个创意是否真的能完全属于某一个人。为了讲述这个故事，我们请来了世界上首屈一指的《Who Let The Dogs Out》专家。是的，这是一个无可争议的头衔。这位是本·西斯托。大约 10 年前，本正在维基百科上阅读巴哈姆人乐队那首《Who Let The Dogs Out》的条目。我注意到这里好像缺少一条引用。
The Wikipedia entry said that the Bahamian didn't actually write the song, but a British hairdresser named Keith had heard it on a trip to Carnival in Chinatown, in Tobago, and that he passed it along to music producers. But it was all very vague. And that made Ben curious, so curious that he spent the next 10 years trying to figure out the answer to what seems like a pretty straightforward question. Who wrote Who Let The Dogs Out? And I just kind of got this journalism bug,
维基百科的条目上说，巴哈姆人其实并没有写这首歌，而是一位名叫基思的英国美发师在去多巴哥唐人街参加狂欢节的旅途中听到了它，然后他把这首歌传给了音乐制作人。但这一切都非常模糊。这引起了本的好奇，好奇心驱使他花了接下来的 10 年时间，试图弄清楚这个看起来相当简单的问题的答案。谁写了《Who Let The Dogs Out》？我当时就是染上了这种新闻记者的狂热，
so I just kept asking people who let the dogs out. And here we are a decade later. Psst. Our story begins in the year 2000, but the release of that song by The Baha Man. I know exactly where I was the first time I heard this song. I saw a game at Pac-Bow Park, it was what it was called then, to see the Giants play. And before the game, The Baha Man came out, played this song, I'd never heard it before, never heard of the Bahamian. It might have been already a hit,
所以我一直追问人们到底是谁放出了狗。十年后的今天，我们就在这里了。嘘。我们的故事始于 2000 年，也就是巴哈姆人乐队发行这首歌的时候。我清楚地记得我第一次听到这首歌时的情景。我在帕克博公园（那是它当时的名称）观看了一场比赛，去看巨人队的比赛。比赛开始前，巴哈姆人乐队出场并演奏了这首歌，我以前从没听过，也从未听说过巴哈姆人。它当时可能已经是一首热门歌曲了，
but it seemed like everyone already knew it. And even if you'd never heard it before, you kind of feel you know the song already, like it has a kind of like Jungian, Urtex kind of quality to it. So who are the Bahamian? So Bahamian are a really hardworking, multi-generational band from the Bahamas, and they've been playing together in one form or another since the 70s.
但似乎每个人都已经知道它了。即使你以前从未听过，你也会觉得自己似乎已经熟悉这首歌了，它有一种类似于荣格心理学中“原型”的特质。那么，巴哈姆人是谁？巴哈姆人是来自巴哈马的一个非常刻苦、跨越好几代的乐队，他们以某种形式从 70 年代就开始一起演奏了。
They started off as a group called High Voltage, sort of playing resorts around the islands, and they've always been known for this style called Junkanew, and that's the music associated with a street parade by the same name, you can think big bright costumes, hundreds of steel drums and cowbells and goat skin drums, just like a big party. This is kind of like the scene that Baja Man are part of. You don't have to worry, or even say a sorry, when you hear the joke of new. They were signed by a young Ann Argy, Steve Greenberg, and he stayed with them across multiple labels and break even releases, and Steve actually ends up being the guy who convinces
他们最初是一个名为“高压”的乐队，主要在岛上的度假村里演出，他们一直以一种名为“容卡努”的风格而闻名，那是与同名街头游行相关的音乐，你可以想象一下巨大的亮丽服装、数以百计的钢鼓、牛铃和山羊皮鼓，就像一场盛大的派对。这有点像是巴哈姆人所处的场景。当你听到容卡努时，你无需担心，甚至不必说抱歉。他们被年轻的 A&R（艺人与 repertory）史蒂夫·格林伯格签下，并在多家唱片公司和零星发行中一直陪伴着他们，最终史蒂夫成了那个说服
them to record who let the dogs out. The song had a really amazing hook, and I'd say one of these days I'm going to figure out how to do this, you know, do this song right, because there's something here, and I just never forgot about the song. I knew that the Bahamian were the people who I wanted to record the song. They just made sense to me. In fact, I used to keep a diary and I wrote in my diary, I'm going to record that song, who let the dogs out with the Bahamian and have a big hit all over the world, I'm certain. This sounds kind of crazy in retrospect, but Bahamian were like, no thanks. The song was already a hit in that area. And
他们录制《Who Let The Dogs Out》的人。这首歌有一个非常惊人的副歌，我当时就想，总有一天我要弄清楚怎么把这首歌做好，你知道的，把这首歌给录好，因为这里面有些东西，而且我对这首歌念念不忘。我知道巴哈姆人就是我想让他们录制这首歌的人。他们对我的胃口。事实上，我过去常常写日记，我在日记里写道，我一定要和巴哈姆人一起录制《Who Let The Dogs Out》这首歌，并且要在全世界引起轰动，我对此深信不疑。回想起来这听起来有点疯狂，但巴哈姆人却说，不用了谢谢。这首歌在该地区已经是一首热门歌曲了，他们
they just didn't think it would be a good look to cover something everybody already knew. I didn't want to do the song. That's why I have to give Steve credit. I'm not gonna actually do anything else just one song. And hey, as a Steve conversation is finished, we will do the song. I'm extremely happy that we did. So why did their producer, Steve, care so much about the song? I think Steve's just one of these guys who knows a hit when he hears it. Steve's also given, for better or worse, the world, he's given the world acts like Hansen. And if there's a song that's going to like play well and stadiums and Disney, yeah, he just knows. So you said the song was already hitting the Bahamas. Is that where
觉得去翻唱一首人尽皆知的东西可能不太光彩。我不想做这首歌。这就是为什么我必须给史蒂夫记上一功。我实际上不会做别的，就只做这一首歌。嘿，既然史蒂夫的谈话结束了，我们就来做这首歌。我极其高兴我们当时这样做了。那么，为什么他们的制作人史蒂夫会如此在意这首歌呢？我认为史蒂夫就是那种一听到热歌就能敏锐识别的人。史蒂夫还给这个世界（无论是好是坏）带来了诸如汉森乐队这样的艺人。如果有哪首歌能在体育场和迪士尼大受欢迎，没错，他就是懂。所以你说这首歌当时已经在巴哈马大火了。那是史蒂夫
he heard it originally, Steve? Yeah. So Steve heard the song via Keith Wainwright, who's like my original kind of Wikipedia mystery guy. And Steve Greenberg kind of instantly knew that there was like something special about the hook and that kind of led to him deciding to pitch it to Baja Man. Yeah. So Steve, here's the song, likes the song. Well, it doesn't really like the song, but likes the hook of the song.
最初听到它的地方吗？是的。所以史蒂夫是通过基思·韦恩赖特听到这首歌的，他就像是我最初了解到的维基百科神秘人物。史蒂夫·格林伯格几乎瞬间就意识到这个副歌有某种特别之处，这促使他决定向巴哈姆人推介这首歌。是的。所以史蒂夫听了这首歌，也很喜欢这首歌。好吧，他其实不是喜欢这首歌，而是喜欢这首歌的副歌。
So who wrote the hook? To find that out, it's the late 90s. So Steve went and as someone did in the late 90s, asked Jeves to come into the website and said Jeves, who let the dogs out. And this led Steve to a message board where people were discussing their vacations and music played at Carnival. This is where Steve first learns that this track is cut by a guy named Anselm Douglas.
那谁写了这段副歌呢？为了找出答案，时间来到了 90 年代末。所以史蒂夫像 90 年代末的人那样，让杰夫打开网站说：“杰夫，谁放出了狗？”这引导史蒂夫来到一个留言板，人们在那里讨论他们的假期以及狂欢节上播放的音乐。史蒂夫就是在这里第一次得知这首歌是由一个名叫安塞尔姆·道格拉斯的家伙创作的。
I'm still amazed that after 20 years it's still out there and playing a new kid's, a new generation is growing up on it. If you don't know the song, who let it go so that you will living under a rock, think about it. What are the songs you know been out there for 20 years and kids every child knows it? So Douglas, who's actually already a known name in the Bahamas music scene, and he wanted to use his platform to write kind of a feminist anthem, like a song that could be this rallying cry for women who are fed up with like the dogs' men behaving poorly on the dance floor.
我仍然很惊奇，20 年过去了，它依然在传唱，新的一代、新的人群伴随着它长大。如果你不知道《Who Let The Dogs Out》这首歌，那你一定就像是隐居山洞一样。想想看。有哪些你所知的歌曲已经问世 20 年，而且每个孩子都知道它？所以道格拉斯，实际上已经是巴哈马音乐界的一个知名人物，他想利用自己的平台写一首某种程度上的女性主义赞歌，就像一首能成为女性的集结号的歌，这些女性受够了那些在舞池里行为不端的“臭男人”。
So do you want to, and we can take a listen? Yeah, it's his version. Totally. That is the song. That's it. Wow. I mean, that seems very clear. So, Anselm Douglas wrote that hook, and that's the thing we think of when we think of this song, we let the dogs out. Although I love the arrangement, actually.
所以你想不想，我们来听听看？是的，这是他的版本。完全是。这就是那首歌。就是这样。哇。我的意思是，这非常清楚。所以，安塞尔姆·道格拉斯写下了这段副歌，这就是我们想到这首歌《Who Let The Dogs Out》时脑海中浮现的东西。不过其实我也很喜欢这个编曲。
Yeah. I do too. And, you know, Douglas is obviously more in the Soko-Colipso tradition and it's more like a take off your shirt, take off your towel, whip it at a high BPM. And the Bahamas is like Americanized hip-hop influence. But the Bahamas version retains this like junk-a-new undertone, which was really important for us crossover movements for the genre. So when it comes to the question, who let the dogs out? The answer is, Anselam Douglas.
是的。我也很喜欢。而且，你知道的，道格拉斯显然更多地延续了索卡-卡利普索音乐的传统，节奏更快，更像是“脱掉你的衬衫，脱掉你的毛巾，用力挥舞”。而巴哈马的版本则带有美式嘻哈的影响。但巴哈马的版本保留了这种容卡努的潜台词，这对于我们这个流派的跨界运动来说非常重要。所以当谈到“谁放出了狗”这个问题时，答案是：安塞尔姆·道格拉斯。
Not quite. Douglas wrote Doggy, but it really wasn't like his idea alone. I never tool anyone. I came up with the phrase, never did, because I didn't. I know that my brother-in-law was the one who said, yeah, you've got to do the song. You've got to do the song. Oh, I don't know. I said, all right, now we'll do it. So he was the one who encouraged me to do it. So I gave him that You got to do the song. Oh, let her do it. I'll say, all right, now we'll do it. Yeah, no. So he was the one who encouraged me to do it.
也不完全是。道格拉斯写了《Doggy》，但这其实并不是他一个人的主意。我从来没对任何人说过这个词组是我发明的，从来没有，因为确实不是。我知道是我小舅子说：“嘿，你得做这首歌。你得做这首歌。”哦，我不知道。我说：“好吧，那我们做吧。”所以他是那个鼓励我做这首歌的人。所以我把这个功劳给了他。你得做这首歌。哦，让她做吧。我说，好吧，那我们做吧。对，没错。所以他是那个鼓励我做这首歌的人。
So I gave him that credit because he was the one who said, do the song. So Douglas's former brother-in-law was the host of this DJ Mix Show, Rec Shop Radio out of Toronto. And two of that shows producers were these guys, Patrick Stephenson and LaRoy Williams, who, you know, they're like writing promos and jingles for it.
所以我把这个功劳归于他，因为他是那个说“做这首歌”的人。所以道格拉斯的前小舅子是多伦多 Rec Shop Radio 的 DJ 混音秀的主持人。该节目的两名制作人是这两个家伙，帕特里克·斯蒂芬森和勒罗伊·威廉姆斯，你知道的，他们是为节目编写宣传片和短歌广告的。
And one of those jingles contained the phrase, who let the dogs out, followed by the sound of dogs barking. And this is late 95, early 96. At the front of the office, I used to go, who let the dogs out? And Marie simply had that and he'd go, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, let the dogs out? You hear the weirdo's going, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, And Murray simply had that and he'd go, Ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho- produce these original recordings. Ooh, let the dogs out! Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor! ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor, hoor!"
其中一首短歌广告包含这样一句词：“Who let the dogs out”，后面紧接着狗叫声。这是 95 年末、96 年初的事。在办公室前台，我经常说：“Who let the dogs out？”默里只是有这个，然后他会说：“Who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who let the dogs out？”你听到那些怪人说：“Who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who”制作这些原创录音。Ooh, let the dogs out! Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor! ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor, hoor!"
["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" Yeah, so that's really it. That's the chorus right there, that's it. Wow. Yeah, I mean, that's the hook. But this part kind of gets a little fuzzy because we'll want it to 20 years ago,
["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" ["Horror, hoor, hoor!" 是的，所以这就是全部了。副歌就在那里，就是这样。哇。是的，我的意思是，这就是副歌。但这一部分有点模糊，因为我们要回溯到 20 年前，
but people involved have different accounts. The long short is that Stephenson and Williams kind of on a handshake agreement told Douglas, like, okay, like, use this, write a song, go down to Carnival, but they didn't think it was gonna become a big hit, and they didn't really know much about like protecting publishing rights at the time.
但参与其中的人的说法各不相同。简而言之，斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯通过击掌为盟的口头协议告诉道格拉斯，好吧，你可以用这个，写首歌，去参加狂欢节吧，但他们当时并不认为这会成为一首热门大热歌曲，而且他们当时对保护版权并不是很了解。
We were so in love with doing the music and being creative, going to become a big hit and they didn't really know much about like protecting publishing rights at the time. We were so in love with doing the music and being creative, but we were passionate about creating and not taking care of the business and the business bit us in the end. Wow. So they like sort of handshake deal, allowed Anselm Douglas to make this carnival song of who let the dogs out called doggy. And then it's the one who gets licensed to the Baha Men to make who let the dogs out. So did Stephenson and Williams know anything about the licensing to the Baha Men? Not until they heard it on the radio.
我们太热爱制作音乐和进行创作了，以为它会成为热门大热歌曲，而且他们当时对保护版权并不是很了解。我们热衷于创作，却不注意商业运作，结果商业问题最终反噬了我们。哇。所以他们通过某种口头协议，允许安塞尔姆·道格拉斯创作这首名为《Doggy》的狂欢节歌曲《Who Let The Dogs Out》。然后这首歌被授权给巴哈姆人乐队，制作成了《Who Let The Dogs Out》。那么斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯知道巴哈姆人获得授权的事吗？直到他们在收音机里听到这首歌才知道。
Oh, that's rough. Yeah, I mean, for a song so happy, it's a very dark moment. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. I'm going to a Jamaican restaurant and hearing this record that we did, and I'm hearing it on the radio. Oh, yeah, we wrote that. And other people are making so much money off this thing. That was just like,
哦，那太惨了。是的，我的意思是，对于一首如此欢快的歌来说，这是一个非常黑暗的时刻。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。我去一家牙买加餐厅，听到这首我们制作的唱片，我在收音机里听到了它。哦，是的，那是我们写的。而其他人正靠这个赚大笔的钱。那感觉就像是，
yeah, it was hard after you found out that someone else is making money off your idea. So there's no official ruling, but Douglas signs in AffityVid, It was hard after you found out that someone else was making money off your idea. So there's no official ruling, but Douglas signs in Affidavid, asserting that Stephenson and Williams were the original authors of the hook, that his work was based on, that gives Douglas the rights to move forward with his own version and licensing.
是的，当你发现别人在靠你的创意赚钱时，这很难接受。所以虽然没有官方裁决，但道格拉斯签署了一份宣誓书，当得知别人在靠你的创意赚钱时，这很难接受。所以虽然没有官方裁决，但道格拉斯签署了一份宣誓书，断言斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯是该副歌的原创作者，他的作品正是基于此创作的，这赋予了道格拉斯继续推进他自己的版本及授权的权利。
Okay, so let me try to get this all straight. So when it comes to who let the dogs out, there's Steve in the Baham and who made the super popular version that most people know. There's Anselam Douglas who made the version from the Bahamas called Doggy that was directly covered in license by the Baham and then there's these DJs who had this brilliant innovation of pairing a rhetorical question with the dogs barking. And so that's incredibly complicated set of people and versions and rights and rights holders and people fighting. It's just kind of stunning. Well, actually, there's more.
好吧，让我试着把这一切理清楚。所以在《Who Let The Dogs Out》这首歌上，有史蒂夫和巴哈姆人乐队，他们创作了大多数人所熟知的超级流行版本。有安塞尔姆·道格拉斯，他创作了巴哈马版本的《Doggy》，该版本被巴哈姆人直接翻唱并获得授权；然后还有这些 DJ，他们有一个绝妙的创意，将一个反问句与狗叫声结合在一起。所以这是一个极其复杂的人员、版本、版权、版权所有者以及产生纠纷的群体网络。这简直令人震惊。其实，还有更多内容。
So what is that? That is a remix of a song called Yura Dog, which is by a group called 20 Fingers featuring the singer Jalette, and that came out in 94. the singer Gillette and that came out in 94. It was a follow-up single to their global kind of mega hit short Dick Man. Do you remember that song? No, it doesn't. It doesn't leave immediately to mind. Well, I mean, as I kind of just implied, short Dick Man was in fact huge. And it's this big, big global hit. And yeah, people were paying attention to these artists
那是什么？那是另一首歌的混音版，名叫《Yura Dog》，演唱者是一个名为 20 Fingers 的组合，主唱是歌手吉莱特（Gillette），该曲发行于 94 年。歌手吉莱特，发行于 94 年。它是他们全球大热单曲《Short Dick Man》的后续单曲。你还记得那首歌吗？不，记不得了。它没有立刻浮现在我的脑海里。好吧，我的意思是，正如我刚才所暗示的，《Short Dick Man》实际上非常火爆。这是一首影响力极大的全球热门歌曲。是的，人们都在关注这些艺人，
and stuff coming out of the Chicago scene. They were sort of like Douglas. They wanted a way to like make a fun record that hit back against some of the like, misogyny that was going on in dance music at the time. Many more who is part of the 20 fingers writing a production team just felt very frustrated by all that. So that's kind of where your dog comes from.
以及出自芝加哥音乐场景的作品。他们有点像道格拉斯。他们想要找到一种方法，创作出一首有趣的唱片，以回击当时舞曲中存在的一些厌女情绪。20 Fingers 词曲创作和制作团队的成员玛尼·摩尔对这一切感到非常沮丧。所以这就是《Yura Dog》这首歌的由来。
So this one was released in 1994. Does that mean that they are like the legally the authors of the song who let the dogs out? So here we kind of need to maybe shift gears and talk about copyright for a sec. Okay. So when you're considering a copyright infringement claim, there's two areas you really want to focus on.
所以这首歌发行于 1994 年。这是否意味着他们在法律上是《Who Let The Dogs Out》这首歌的作者？在这里，我们可能需要转换一下思路，花点时间谈谈版权问题。好的。当你考虑侵犯版权的诉讼时，有两个方面是你真正需要关注的。
And there are access and similarity. The latter similarity is pretty straightforward. It's like, do these things look or sound the same? But even if two things seem very similar, which of course is subjective, like courts will recognize there's a finite number of ways to arrange notes and words, so you also have to consider this concept of access, which, in short, means was the alleged infringer aware of the plaintiffs' work.
那就是接触（Access）和相似性（Similarity）。后者“相似性”很简单。就是说：这些东西看起来或听起来一样吗？但即使两件东西看起来非常相似（当然这具有主观性），法院也会承认排列音符和词语的方式是有限的，所以你还必须考虑“接触”这个概念，简而言之，这意味着所谓的侵权方是否知道原告的作品。
Like, what's the line between copying and coincidence? Okay. And so did the Canadian DJs? did they hear this song by Gillette? Stephenson and Williams claim to have never heard of a song or anything about 20 fingers. Based on Gillette's charting and billboard and stuff, I find that a little tough to believe, but I have to take them at their word. And so legally, does Gillette and 20 fingers have a case that their copyright had been infringed?
比如说，抄袭和巧合之间的界限在哪里？好的。那么加拿大的 DJ 们，他们听过吉莱特的这首歌吗？斯蒂芬森和威廉姆斯声称从未听说过这首歌，也对 20 Fingers 一无所知。根据吉莱特的打榜情况以及公告牌等数据，我觉得这有点难以置信，但我只能相信他们的话。所以在法律上，吉莱特和 20 Fingers 是否有理由控告他们的版权受到侵犯？
I think they did, but at the time their label didn't want to pursue it. You know, there's a joke about copyright being the right to be held up in court until your bankrupt. And if you're like an indie, if you're like an indie label or something like that, you might not have the resources and assets to sue a major label who can just kind of treat their legal expenses the same way one might like marketing costs. You know, it's kind of all the same pot as long as you have like a net positive result.
我认为他们是有的，但当时他们的唱片公司不想追究。你知道，有一个关于版权的笑话，说版权就是“法庭上被拖到破产的权利”。如果你是一个独立厂牌或者类似的公司，你可能没有资源和资产去起诉一家大唱片公司，因为大唱片公司完全可以把法律开支当作和营销成本一样的东西来处理。你知道，只要你最终能带来净正面的结果，这其实都是一回事。
Okay, that makes sense. So I guess the DJs are the ones with the legal claim to the song because they weren't challenged by 20 fingers But 20 fingers can say that they are the original authors of the song Not so fast for them That's one of these people. This is Miami Boom Productions of Jacksonville, Florida with their song Who Let The Dogs Out, which was written and recorded in 1992. Goodness. This duo is Brett Hammock and Joe Gonzalez.
好吧，这说得通。所以我猜这些 DJ 才是对这首歌拥有合法诉求的人，因为他们没有被 20 Fingers 挑战。但 20 Fingers 可以说他们才是这首歌的原创作者。没那么快轮到他们。还有另一个人。这是来自佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔的 Miami Boom Productions，他们的歌曲《Who Let The Dogs Out》于 1992 年创作并录制。天哪。这个二人组是布雷特·哈莫克（Brett Hammock）和乔·冈萨雷斯（Joe Gonzalez）。
They're stage names at the time, Be Nasty and Miami J. Who are basically just like cool teenagers and they want to write, produce, and perform Miami-based music. That was it. That was everything to them. I actually had someone call me
他们当时的艺名是 Be Nasty 和 Miami J. 他们基本上就是一群酷酷的青少年，想要创作、制作和表演迈阿密风格的音乐。就是这样。这对他们来说就是全部。我甚至接到过别人的电话，
and they're like, hey, I heard you and Joe's song on the radio and I was like, no, you didn't. And he was like, oh, yeah, I swear to you, who let the dog of that? I just heard it on the radio. we flipped it on and I'm just thinking somebody ripped off our track. Wow. So this is another set of people completely blindsided by hearing the Bahamans who let the dogs out on the radio. Completely. And there's actually this kind of amazing story of where they came up with the hook.
他们说：“嘿，我在收音机里听到你和乔的歌了。”我说：“不，你绝对没听过。”然后他说：“哦，真的，我向你发誓，就是那个‘Who let the dog’，我刚刚在收音机里听到了。”我们把它打开，我脑子里只想著：有人盗版了我们的音轨。哇。所以这是另一群人，完全被在收音机里听到巴哈姆人的《Who Let The Dogs Out》给惊呆了。完全是。而且关于他们是如何想出这个副歌的，还有一个非常神奇的故事。
So these guys are, they're driving around Florida and their parents, Chevy Astro Van, they've taken the back seats out to make room for extra speakers and they're blasting this album Kings of Base by Base Patrol. On that album, there's a song called Demand Scientist and very, very low in the mix. Like, you can barely hear it if you're not looking for it. There is a sample and Bret and Joe didn't know what it said. They're making up lyrics and at some point they just said, who let the dogs out and kind of stuck.
这些人当时正开着父母的雪佛兰阿斯特罗面包车在佛罗里达兜风，他们拆掉了后排座椅，好腾出空间放下额外的扬声器，然后他们在大声播放 Base Patrol 乐队的专辑《Kings of Base》。在这张专辑里，有一首歌叫《Deman Scientist》，声音在混音中非常非常低。如果你不特意去听，几乎都听不到。里面有一个采样，布雷特和乔不知道它唱的是什么。他们自己编歌词，在某个时刻，他们随口说出了“Who let the dogs out”，然后就卡在脑子里了。
I just started throwing my arms out. Oh, let the dogs let me drive. He didn't take me as mocking him. He started doing it too. So we're jumping around, hopping around, singing this song we just made up. And I looked at him, I said, he looks a pretty good hook. That sample is actually saying who's rockin' this dog's house.
我开始甩开双手。哦，让狗放我开车吧。他没有觉得我在模仿他。他也开始这么做了。所以我们蹦蹦跳跳，唱着这首我们刚编出来的歌。我看着他，对他说：“这听起来是个相当不错的副歌。”那个采样其实唱的是：“Who's rockin' this dog's house”。
And it comes from Pump Up the Party by Hassan. We should take a listen to this one. It's not exactly the same. I would argue the Miami boom stuff is transformative enough to be considered a new work, but you can really hear the seeds of it. So this is the thing that Miami Boom heard and turned it into their version of who let the dogs out. Correct. You can see how it's a progenitor, but it does seem like the leap between the two versions is greater than this one, as opposed to a lot of the other ones that we've heard today.
它出自 Hassan 的《Pump Up the Party》。我们应该听听这首。它不完全一样。我认为 Miami Boom 的东西经过了足够的改造，可以被视为一处新作品，但你确实能从中听到它的种子。这就是 Miami Boom 听到并将其转化为他们版本的《Who Let The Dogs Out》的东西。没错。你能看出它是前身，但与我们今天听到的许多其他版本相比，这两个版本之间的跨度似乎更大一些。
I would say this is more an instance of influence than copying. Right. Okay, so Miami Boom wrote this song in 1992. And was it released? Did other people hear it? Very few. And I only became aware of it because they had posted it to YouTube, which isn't really great for copyright dating purposes, because it's like, who knows when it was recorded.
我认为这与其说是抄袭，不如说是一次受到启发。没错。好吧，所以 Miami Boom 在 1992 年写了这首歌。它发行了吗？其他人听过吗？极少数人。我之所以知道它，是因为他们把它发布到了 YouTube 上，这对于确定版权日期来说并不是什么好事，因为这就像是：谁知道它是什么时候录制的呢。
But after kind of earning their trust over a couple of years and stuff, they eventually produced a bunch of stuff like old flyers and one of the best things they produce with these floppy disks that had the original vocals and samples from the recording session. In that box of floppy, is there was even the original receipt from the Kmart where they bought them in Florida. So that was like one way of dating it. Then I took those disks to a data preservation company in the UK called Cryoflux,
但在经过几年左右逐渐赢得他们的信任等过程后，他们最终拿出了许多东西，比如旧传单，他们拿出的最好的东西之一是这些软盘，里面保存着录音时的原始人声和采样。在那箱软盘中，甚至还有他们当年在佛罗里达州的 Kmart 买下这些软盘的原始收据。所以这是确定日期的一种方式。然后我把这些软盘带到了英国的一家数据恢复公司，名叫 Cryoflux，
who helped me identify the hardware that would have been used, and then I found a DJ who had this piece of hardware and we open them up, all the samples were there. And this DJ and producer, his name is Mishna, he's also from Florida, knows a lot about Miami-Base and he kind of verified for me There was no way that this was fake Once you determine the veracity of Their song that it was out there in the world does Miami boom also feel like they're owed something like in terms of the copyright of who let the dogs out? They definitely do and I think they also want credit given to their
他们帮我确定了当时可能使用的硬件，然后我找到了一位拥有这种硬件的 DJ，我们打开了它们，所有的采样都在里面。这位名叫米什纳（Mishna）的 DJ 兼制作人也来自佛罗里达，对迈阿密贝斯音乐了解甚多，他为我进行了核实：这绝不可能是伪造的。一旦你确定了他们的歌曲真实存在于世，Miami Boom 是否也觉得自己应该得到一些补偿，比如就《Who Let The Dogs Out》的版权而言？他们绝对是这么认为的，而且我认为他们还希望给他们的录音师署名，她的名字叫 Mama Do。
studio engineer her name was Mama Do. When I think about the times making this music it was phenomenal. It was the best times of my life. The bottom line is I know where we believe it came from. There's three names messing from that song, and they're sitting right here. We should own that song. The story is fun because the song is kind of funny and light, and it's a carnival song. But there's a real sadness to this. Yeah, it's difficult as an artist to think about people who aren't given proper attribution. You know, like being cut out of a financial deal is one thing, but to be unknown when your
每当我回想起制作这些音乐的时光，那真是妙不可言。那是我一生中最美好的时光。底线是，我知道我们认为它来自哪里。那首歌里有三个名字不见了，而他们就坐在此时此地。我们本该拥有那首歌。这个故事很有趣，因为这首歌本身挺搞笑、轻松的，而且是一首狂欢节歌曲。但这里面有一种真正的悲伤。是的，作为一名艺术家，想到那些没有得到应有署名的人，这让人很难受。你知道，被踢出商业交易是一回事，但当你的歌曲全球闻名时，你却籍籍无名，我想这很伤人。
song is known globally, I think hurts. Yeah. Okay, so I feel like I need to recap here a little bit. So let's go through all the versions. So first, here's the Bahamian playing the version that we all know. Who let the dogs out? Which they got from Anselm Douglas in the Bahamas. Which he got from the Canadian radio DJs in the mid 90s.
好的，我觉得我需要在这里做个小结。让我们过一遍所有的版本。首先，这里是巴哈姆人乐队演奏我们大家都知道的版本：《Who Let The Dogs Out》？他们是从巴哈马的安塞尔姆·道格拉斯那里得到的灵感。而道格拉斯又是从 90 年代中期加拿大电台 DJ 那里得到的。
But before them Gillette and 20 Fingers wrote this version in Chicago in 1994. Before that Miami Boom wrote this in 1922. Yeah, Roman, I hate to keep doing this to you, but there is more. So what is that? Yeah. After I started doing some research and getting a little pressed, this guy, John Michael Davis from Duwajak, Michigan, learned about what I was doing and gotten touched. He told me this story that starts in 1990 in Duwajak. Then it was sort of like a down and out place.
但在他们之前，吉莱特和 20 Fingers 于 1994 年在芝加哥创作了这一版本。在此之前，Miami Boom 于 1922 年（注：应为1992年）创作了这首歌。是的，罗曼，我很抱歉一直对你这么说，但还有更多。那是什么？是的。在我开始做一些研究并承受了一点压力之后，这位来自密歇根州多瓦贾克的约翰·迈克尔·戴维斯（John Michael Davis）了解了我在做的事并和我取得了联系。他给我讲了一个始于 1990 年在多瓦贾克的故事。当时那里有点像个破落的地方。
I had this nickname, the dog patch. And the town really needed like something to rally around. So John tells me this like Rudy like tail of high school football, where there's like a Hail Mary pass and he just starts chanting, ooh, ooh, let the dogs out. And then the whole stadium starts chanting it. And then yeah, it just happens.
我有个绰号叫“狗群地”（dog patch）。这个镇子真的很需要某种凝聚人心的东西。所以约翰给我讲了一个类似于电影《追梦赤子心》（Rudy）的高中橄榄球传奇故事，当时有一个“万福玛丽”（Hail Mary）式的长传绝杀，他开始带领大家呐喊：“Ooh, ooh, let the dogs out”。接着整个体育场都跟着呐喊起来。然后，是的，事情就这么发生了。
I should preface and say, that's how he remembers it. Other people from this football team don't remember it that way. Some people told me a guy named Keith the funky bus driver came up with it. It's kind of a mystery, but what's important is this team blew up. They won the state champion and this chant was their motto. So as part of the research, we visited
我需要先说明并指出，这是他的记忆。这支橄榄球队的其他成员并不这么认为。有些人告诉我，是一个叫基思的时髦公交车司机想出来的。这有点像个谜，但重要的是这支球队火了。他们赢得了州冠军，而这个口号就是他们的座右铭。作为研究的一部分，我们拜访了
Duwajak and just like locals were like, oh, what are you guys doing here? Oh, we're researching who let the dogs out. And people just start giving us VHS tapes and like old silk screens and there's just all this stuff there with who let the dogs out on it from 1990. This team's coach was named Bernard Thomas and he was so beloved they called him Saint Bernard. His players were like his dogs and it just like it just made sense. So is the assertion that they're making is that this football chant traveled down to Miami to to inspire Miami boom?
多瓦贾克，当地人一看到我们就问：“哦，你们来这里干什么？”“哦，我们在研究是谁放出了狗。”人们开始给我们送 VHS 录像带、旧丝网印刷品，到处都是带有 1990 年“是谁放出了狗”字样的东西。这支球队的教练名叫伯纳德·托马斯（Bernard Thomas），他备受爱戴，人们甚至叫他“圣伯纳德”。他的球员们就像他的狗一样，所以这一切都说得通。所以他们的断言是，这个橄榄球口号传到了迈阿密，从而启发了 Miami Boom？
I think they're not sure where it traveled to next or how but get this Joe from Miami boom is originally from Michigan until he was like eight years old or something. So I plotted this Google map of all the places the chant appeared in Michigan after the Duwajak Chief Dins had this great victory year. And that map formed a near perfect circle around Joe's hometown. So I was like, are you kidding me?
我认为他们不确定这个口号接下来传到了哪里，又是如何传过去的，但你听这个：Miami Boom 的乔最初来自密歇根州，直到他大约八岁左右。于是我用谷歌地图标出了那个口号在多瓦贾克酋长队度过辉煌胜利的一年之后在密歇根州出现过所有地方。而那张地图在乔的家乡周围画出了一个近乎完美的圆。所以我当时想：你在开玩笑吧？
So it just looked so clean. So I got in touch with Joe and he verified for me that he was there that summer visiting family, but he says he's got absolutely no memory of hearing the chat. But also when I pressed him with the evidence, he wasn't overly defensive about it So as it turns out who let the dogs out let the dogs out let the some dogs loose These are all phrases that actually pop up here and there in regionals, high school sports, long before someone recorded a song, before Stevie B.
这一切看起来太完美了。于是我联系了乔，他向我证实他那年夏天确实在那儿探亲，但他坚称自己对听到过这个口号毫无印象。不过当我用证据质问他时，他并没有表现得过分防御。所以事实证明，“Who let the dogs out”、“let the dogs out”、“let the some dogs loose”，这些其实都是在有人录制歌曲之前、在 Stevie B 之前很久，就零星出现在地区性高中体育赛事中的短语。
So I'm scouring like all these old newspaper archives. The earliest I've been able to find was from 1986, the Austin Reagan High School in Austin, Texas Their team the Raiders used it Oh, Molly Yeah, that's that's from a pep rally and it's just a weird like couple of seconds Embedded in this much longer, chronicling the football team. It's been on YouTube this whole time. And what year is that?
所以我一直在仔细搜寻所有这些旧报纸档案。我能找到的最早记录是在 1986 年，德克萨斯州奥斯汀的奥斯汀里根高中（Austin Reagan High School）。他们的球队“突袭者队”（Raiders）使用过它。哦，莫莉。是的，那是来自一场助威集会，这只是一段奇怪的好几秒钟的片段，嵌入在这个记录这支橄榄球队的长篇内容中。它一直在 YouTube 上。那是哪一年？
1986. I mean, that sounds more like the last version, you know, like the final version than even some of the ones in between. Roman, it's a wild ride. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness.
1986 年。我的意思是，听起来比中间的某些版本更像最终版本，你知道的，就像是终极版本。罗曼，这真是一段疯狂的旅程。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。
Oh my goodness. So is this, have we finally reached the bedrock of who let the dogs out? Do we actually know who let the dogs out at this point? Well, this is as far back as I can go. The title of the Bahamian song doesn't have a question mark in it and I'm just going to have to look into it all this time. I just have to accept that maybe it's not a question, it's probably unanswerable. I mean, when you started this, did you think it would be this hard to determine who wrote a single song? No way. I think if I had known I would not have done this. But you know, it is a nice surprise and there's been a lot of nice surprises along the way.
噢，天哪。所以，我们终于找到了《Who Let The Dogs Out》的源头了吗？此时此刻我们真的知道是谁放出了狗吗？好吧，这是我能追溯到的最远的地方了。巴哈姆人歌曲的标题里其实没有问号，我不得不花这么多时间去调查。我只能接受这样一个事实：也许这根本不是一个问题，它大概是无法回答的。我的意思是，当你开始做这件事时，你以为查明一首单曲是谁写的会这么难吗？绝不可能。我想如果我知道的话，我就不会这么做了。但你知道，这也是一个不错的惊喜，这一路上有很多美好的惊喜。
I got to meet all these cool people and producers. Maybe I would have done it again. Yeah. There are all these sort of like ways in which people borrow and they take in information. It comes process in their brains. They maybe they spit it out as an homage or maybe they don't know where it comes process in their brains, they may be they spit it out as an homage or maybe they don't know where it comes from. Do you think about how a song is passed between different people, or some of them lying, or none of them lying? Where do you stand in everyone's story in this story?
我结识了所有这些酷炫的人和制作人。也许我还是会再做一次。是的。人们以各种方式去借用和吸收信息。这些信息在他们的大脑中经过处理。也许他们会以致敬的方式把它表达出来，或者他们自己都不知道它来自哪里。你觉得一首歌曲在不同人之间传递时是怎么样的？他们当中有人在撒谎吗，还是都没撒谎？在这则故事中，你对每个人的说法持什么立场？
I don't think anybody in this story is lying and I actually think people have been pretty forthcoming and open to the notion that you can hear something and it's just in there subconsciously until like it's ready to come out. I think one of the big myths we tell ourselves about art is that it's like made by individuals and that myth is sort of what the art market is like propped up on. I mean, like for my own experience, I vividly remember being 20 at art school.
我不认为这个故事里的任何人是在撒谎，而且我实际上认为人们一直非常坦诚，并乐于接受这样一种观点：你可能会听到某些东西，它就潜意识地留在你脑海里，直到它准备好破茧而出。我认为关于艺术，我们告诉自己的一个最大神话就是它是“由个人创作的”，而艺术市场基本上就是靠这个神话支撑起来的。我的意思是，就我自己的经历而言，我清晰地记得自己 20 岁在艺术学校的时候。
I had this idea to like, you know, wood shop class to make a box. And the box was gonna have an audio tape that contained the sound of the box being made, just like youthful conceptual daydream or whatever. This was my idea until like years later I learned that Robert Morris created a work in 1961 called Box with the Sound of its Own Making.
我当时有个想法，在木工课上做一个盒子。这个盒子将包含一个录音带，里面录制的是这个盒子被制作时的声音，这只是一种充满青春气息的概念化白日梦什么的。这就是我的想法，直到多年后我才知道罗伯特·莫里斯（Robert Morris）在 1961 年创作了一件名为《有其自身制作声音的盒子》（Box with the Sound of Its Own Making）的作品。
So it's like, I don't know, did I get the idea from him? Was it coincidence? Was it copying? I just can't tell you. And I think that's what's cool about all the dog stuff is like, it's just about the very nature of art and life. And I think that all these ideas apply to like every piece of creative work ever made.
所以这就好像是：我不知道，我是从他那里得到这个创意的吗？这只是巧合吗？还是抄袭？我实在说不准。我认为所有这些关于狗的故事最酷的地方就在于，它关乎艺术和生活的本质。我认为所有这些观点同样适用于有史以来创作的每一件创意作品。
Well, that's so cool. Well, I really appreciate you taking us on this journey. And, you know, maybe we'll never know the answer to who let the dogs out, but the question is still worth asking. Well, thanks for having me. I'm surprised many times before wanting to hear me talk about this, but yeah, it was a lot of fun. Thank you. It certainly surprised me to learn that who let the dogs out doesn't actually have a question mark, but titles that are grammatically questions without actually being written as questions are surprisingly common.
哇，太酷了。我真的很感激你带我们踏上这段旅程。而且，你知道，也许我们永远不会知道谁放出了狗这个问题的答案，但这个问题依然值得一问。谢谢你邀请我。此前很多人让我谈论这个话题时我都感到很惊讶，但确实，这非常有趣。谢谢你。得知《Who Let The Dogs Out》实际上并没有问号，这确实让我感到惊讶，但在语法上属于疑问句却不用问号结尾的标题，其实出奇地普遍。
More on that after this. So I'm in this video with Chris Perube and you're actually in town. I am. I'm in Oakland, California. That's amazing. It's so good to have you here. It's great to be here. And you helped us put together this episode on Who Let The Dogs Out. And one of the things that is kind of remarkable that is hard to convey in a podcast is that there is a kind of quirk to the title Who Let The Dogs Out.
广告之后将为您带来更多内容。所以我和克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）正在做这个视频，而你实际上就在城里。是的。我在加利福尼亚州奥克兰。太棒了。很高兴你能来到这里。能来这里太棒了。你帮我们制作了这期关于《Who Let The Dogs Out》的节目。其中有一点非常引人注目，但在播客中很难传达出来，那就是《Who Let The Dogs Out》这个标题有一个某种程度上的小怪癖。
Yes. And that is, is that it isn't a question. It doesn't end in a question. Who Let The Dogs Out. Yes. And that is, is that it isn't a question. It doesn't end in a question. Who Let The Dogs Out is just the end of it. There's no question mark at the end of it. Yeah, it's a statement effect, which is really strange. And actually, it reminded me when Ben was talking about the question mark, it reminded
是的。那就是：它不是一个问句。它不以问号结尾。“Who Let The Dogs Out”。是的。那就是：它不是一个问句。它不以问号结尾。“Who Let The Dogs Out”到这里就结束了。结尾没有问号。是的，这是一个陈述句，这真的很奇怪。事实上，当本在谈论问号时，这让我想起了
me of something that happened to me a year ago. So I was hanging out with my friend Liz, who's a movie producer. We watch a lot of movies together, and she's like, hey, have you seen Who Frame Roger Rabbit? And I tried watching it as a kid. It's really scary when you're a little kid because they're very mean to the cartoons. So I was like, you know what?
一年前发生在我身上的事。当时我和我的朋友莉兹（Liz）在一起，她是一位电影制片人。我们经常一起看电影，她说：“嘿，你看过《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》吗？”我小时候尝试看过来着。如果你年纪很小的话，这部电影真的很吓人，因为他们对动画片太刻薄了。所以我当时就想，你知道吗？
Yes, let's give it another try. Let's put it on. So she turns the movie on, and then immediately, I'm like, oh, there's something really weird about this movie. And she's like, oh, that the humans and cartoons are interacting, I'm like, oh, there's something really weird about this movie. And she's like, oh, the humans and cartoons are interacting. I'm like, no, that is fine, that is logically consistent to me. There is something else, like, right when the movie starts that really bothered me.
好，我们再试一次。把它放来看看吧。于是她打开了电影，紧接着，我就觉得：噢，这部电影有点非常奇怪。她说：“噢，是因为人类和动画片在互动吗？”我说：“不，那没问题，这对我来说逻辑上讲得通。是别的东西，就在电影刚开始的时候，有些东西真的让我很困扰。”
It starts with a very lovely kind of jazzy, low, blue note. And then the movie's titles fade onto screen. It's literally the first visual of the film. these titles fade onto screen. It's literally the first visual of the film. And it's who framed Roger Rabbit except instead of a question mark, it is phrased with an exclamation point at the end. So not who framed Roger Rabbit,
它以一个非常美妙的、带点爵士乐风格的、低沉的蓝调音符开场。然后电影的字幕淡入屏幕。这字面意思上就是这部电影的第一个视觉画面。这些字幕淡入屏幕。这字面意思上就是这部电影的第一个视觉画面。那是“Who framed Roger Rabbit”，只不过结尾没有用问号，而是用了一个感叹号。所以不是“Who framed Roger Rabbit？”
but who framed Roger Rabbit? So that's my friend Liz who I watched the movie with. And she told me there's a very specific reason for that. And it's because the director of the movie, Robert Semeckis, gave this interview where he said, there is a superstition in Hollywood that if you put a question mark at the end of your title, the movie will bomb at the box office. And when you think about it, there's lots of examples that back that up. So like, what's eating Gilbert Grape is a statement of facts. Statement, okay.
而是“Who framed Roger Rabbit！”所以那是和我一起看电影的朋友莉兹。她告诉我，这背后有一个非常具体的原因。那是因为这部电影的导演罗伯特·赞米基斯（Robert Zemeckis）在接受采访时曾说过，好莱坞流传着一种迷信：如果在片名结尾加上问号，这部电影在票房上就会惨败。当你仔细想想，有很多例子都能证明这一点。比如，《不一样的天空》（What's Eating Gilbert Grape）就是一个事实陈述句。陈述句，对吧。
What's love got to do with it with Tina Turner is also a statement. And what's weird about it though is this is not a superstition that everyone follows. So there's lots of examples where they don't use the question mark and there's lots of examples where they do. Say for example, guess who's coming to dinner? I think it came out in 1967.
蒂娜·特纳的《与爱何干》（What's Love Got to Do with It）也是一个陈述句。不过奇怪的是，这并不是每个人都遵循的迷信。所以有很多例子没有使用问号，但也有很多例子使用了问号。比如说，1967 年上映的《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》（Guess Who's Coming to Dinner）？我想它是 1967 年上映的。
It's a huge, huge hit. It's got fence or treasy. It's got Sydney, Pau allier. It's guess who's coming to dinner? No question mark. And I always took that as an example of a movie. They're like, okay, they followed the rule. Contemporaneously, you have who's afraid of Virginia Woolf, which is like Liz Taylor's
这是一个巨大、巨大、巨大的热门。它有《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》？没有问号。我总是把它当作一部电影的例子。他们会想，好吧，他们遵循了规则。同时，你还有《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫？》，这就像是伊丽莎白·泰勒的
huge, huge, huge, come back, massive, massive, massive hit. You have, they shoot horses, don't they, starting Jane Fonda. That's got a question mark. That's a huge hit. So it's not precise. So you have movies like Guess Who's Coming to Dinner, which do really well, but then you have all these other movies at the same time, which we're also doing well. So Liz and I were like looking through all these titles in history and trying to figure out like some pattern or some rhyme or reason to why you put in a question mark.
巨大、巨大、巨大的卷土重来，一部超级、超级、超级热门。你有简·方达主演的《他们射杀马，不是吗？》。那里面有一个问号。那是一个巨大的热门。所以它并不精确。所以你有一些像《猜猜谁来吃晚餐》这样的电影，它们票房很好，但同时你还有所有这些其他电影，它们也同样表现很好。所以我和莉兹一直在翻看历史上的所有这些标题，试图找出某种模式，或者找出为什么你要加上一个问号的某种情理或原因。
And what we noticed is that there's lots of dramas that don't use question marks. So what's even Gilbert Grape, you know, really serious movie. But comedies use them all the time. So, dude, where's my car? That is a question. Yeah. A brother where I at though. That's a pretty goofy film. That is also a question. Yeah. And Liz's theory about this is it's really, the question mark really sets you up for a certain kind of mood. I would say sort of a zaniness or wistfulness. It's sort of like one or the other. So you have what about Bob, which has a question mark at the end, because it's kind of like, what about Bob? And it makes you feel kind of like cheerful and goofy.
而我们注意到的是，有很多剧情片并不使用问号。比如《不一样的天空》（What's Eating Gilbert Grape），你知道，这是一部非常严肃的电影。但喜剧片却一直在使用它们。所以，兄弟，我的车呢？那是一个问题。是啊。还有《兄弟，你在哪儿？》。那是一部挺滑稽的电影。那也是一个问题。是啊。而莉兹关于这一点的理论是，真的，问号确实能为你营造某种特定的情绪。我想可以说是一种滑稽或怀旧。它有点像两者之一。所以你有了《关于鲍勃》，它的结尾带有一个问号，因为它有点像“关于鲍勃呢？”，这会让你感觉有点像个高兴的滑稽鬼。
Like, you're waiting for the punchline, you're waiting for the shoot or drop. It's like being told the first half of a joke. So ultimately, there's kind of no rhyme or reason to this. Like, there's lots of movies with question marks. There's lots of movies with that question marks. But what Liz explained to me, which is interesting, is it really isn't keeping with how the movie industry
就像你在等待包袱，你在等待靴子落地。这就像是听了一个笑话的上半句。所以归根结底，这其实没有什么情理或原因。比如，有很多电影带有问号。有很多电影不带问号。但莉兹向我解释的事情很有趣，它其实并不符合电影工业
makes decisions, that one thing does really well, and then they kind of try to guess if that thing is gonna do well. What was the thing that did it? Again. So she says it's part of this bigger pattern where people are trying to guess things in this industry where success can sometimes feel totally random.
做出决策的方式——即某样东西表现得很好，然后他们就会去猜测那东西是否会再次大卖。是什么东西做到了这一点？再次。所以她说这是更大模式的一部分，在这个行业里，人们试图去猜测那些成功有时看起来完全是随机的事情。
You can't fully predict how people are going to act. And so people get very, very into these like, nitty gritty sort of, you know, like, oh, people don't like leads with blonde hair this year. That remake flops were never gonna make remakes for like 15 more years. That musical did really well. So now we're gonna do 30 more musicals.
你无法完全预测人们会如何行动。因此，人们会非常、非常深陷于这些细枝末节的事情中，你知道的，比如“哦，今年人们不喜欢金发的主角”。那部翻拍片扑街了，我们以后15年都不会再拍翻拍片了。那部音乐剧表现很好，所以现在我们要拍30部更多的音乐剧。
I mean, like these kind of superstitions are just trying to put lighten it in a bottle and trying to like apply any kind of rhyme or reason to what is ultimately like such a multi-variant and shifting public mood that will put or not put money in your pocket that you'll latch on to stuff like question marks in the titles which is like the equivalent of wearing the same pair of shorts for every NCAA finals game you play in. So, ultimately, there's kind of no answer to the mystery, except to say that all creativity and art is a mystery.
我的意思是，这类迷信只是试图将闪电装进瓶子里，试图为最终如此多变且不断摇摆的公众情绪找出任何情理或原因，而这种情绪决定了钱是否会进你的口袋，以至于你会抓住像标题中的问号这样的东西不放，这就像在参加每一场NCAA总决赛时都穿同一条短裤一样。所以，归根结底，这个谜团并没有答案，只能说所有的创造力和艺术都是一个谜。
And what I think I take some kind of delight in is the potential that there's these sweaty people and suits, like, really vexed over whether or not a question mark should go next to the title or not Absolutely, and like what is this what is this telling our audience if we are telling them dude. Where is my car? As a complete sentence. No, oh I kind of love it. I so I guess I you know There's so much of what we do on the show is to think about all the thought that goes into things. And often the result is a beautiful object or a functioning street or a curb cut or whatever.
而我认为我从中获得一些乐趣的是这种可能性：有一群穿着西装汗流浃背的人，真的在为标题旁边是否应该加上一个问号而感到十分纠结。绝对的，比如如果我们对观众说“兄弟，我的车呢？”作为一个完整的句子，这在向我们的观众传达什么？不，哦，我有点爱死它了。所以我想我，你知道的，我们在节目中所做的很多事情，都是在思考倾注在事物中的所有巧思。通常结果是一个美丽的物件、一条正常运转的街道、一个路缘斜坡，或者诸如此类。
And this is truly like deck chairs on the Titanic. I mean, this is like, this is truly, we don't know how this works. We don't know what it's going on. It's probably means nothing. Right. We're going to make all sorts of decisions. It's going to be a meeting about it. So it is a whole meeting to decide whether or not dude wears my car is a statement or a question.
而这真的就像泰坦尼克号上的躺椅。我的意思是，这真的就像，我们不知道这是怎么运作的。我们不知道发生了什么。它可能毫无意义。没错。我们要做出各种各样的决定。将会为此开个会。所以这真的是一个全体会议，来决定“兄弟，我的车呢？”究竟是一个陈述句还是一个疑问句。
And if that is going to influence whether a teenager is going to go see that movie. Oh, I love it. I love it. Okay, well, that's, you know, and mystery unsolved, but I'll now think of it whenever I see a poster and, you know, like, and someone deciding that this is a declarative statement versus an a query, which is awesome.
以及这是否会影响一个青少年是否会去看那部电影。哦，我爱死它了。我爱死它了。好吧，那就是，你知道的，未解之谜，但每当我看到海报时我都会想到这一点，你知道的，有人在决定这是一个陈述句还是一个疑问句，这太棒了。
Cool. Thanks, Chris. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin. Thanks, Robin.
太棒了。谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。谢谢你，罗宾。
99% Invisible was Produced This Week by Ben Sisto and Chris Baroube edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. There is a whole documentary about Ben's investigation called Who Let The Dogs Out. And it goes into a bunch of detail we couldn't fit into this episode. It is delightful to watch. You can watch it on iTunes or Amazon. Special thanks this week to Brent Hosh, Ali Kelly, and Jazzling Corp for providing audio for this episode, and thanks to Liz Watson for the story about who framed Roger Rapid. Not a question. Mix in Tech Production by Sriviusif, Additional Music by Sean Rial with Barking by Carrot Riddle Rial. Carrot.
本周的《99%无形》由本·西斯托（Ben Sisto）和克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）剪辑。有一部关于本的调查的完整纪录片叫做《谁把狗放出来了》。它深入探讨了许多我们无法塞进这一集的细节。观看它是一种享受。你可以在iTunes或Amazon上观看。本周特别感谢布伦特·霍什（Brent Hosh）、阿里·凯利（Ali Kelly）和爵士灵公司（Jazzling Corp）为本集提供音频，并感谢莉兹·沃森（Liz Watson）讲述了关于《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》的故事。这不是个问号。混音制作由斯里维尤西夫（Sriviusif）完成，额外音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作，伴有卡罗特·里德尔·里亚尔（Carrot Riddle Rial）的叫声。卡罗特。
Baby. Baby. Baby. Katie Mingle is a senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Avery Trouffleman saw the Who Let The Dogs Out documentary and insisted we make an episode about it. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg and me Roman Mars.
宝贝。宝贝。宝贝。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）看了《谁把狗放出来了》纪录片并坚持让我们做一个关于它的节目。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi org on Instagram and read it too. But the original home of 99% invisible. But there's no mystery. It's all there just waiting for you at n-i-i-p-i dot org.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的无线电街（Radio Row）。《99%无形》是来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia 成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们全部。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，在 Instagram 上@节目 99pi org，也可以在 Reddit 上找到。但《99%无形》最初的家。不过这里没有谜团。它全都在那里，正等着你在 99pi.org 上发现。
Do you actually like the song itself? I'm indifferent. Radio til P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你真的喜欢这首歌本身吗？我无所谓。Radio Topia P.R.X. 本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。